Continental Tire coaches corner from
Sunday rain to snow and everything in
between Continental Tire is engineered
to tire for what you do extraordinary
performance reliability putting
confidence into driving for more info
and the location of a dealer near you
visit Continental Tire dot-com I'm tired
for what you do Continental Tire Coaches
Corner
the former coach Seth Greenberg working
for the mothership last night on their
college basketball telecast and he joins
us now you know you and J waves were
going back and forth talking about what
you think should happen to the UCLA kids
you said sit him down the entire season
J said you know let's give him five
games did you know J was gonna be that
fired up with your suggestion yeah I
didn't know I mean J will and I had
people don't us now we are so close and
really dear friends and now sometimes we
look at things through a different prism
I mean it's really that that's simple
but uh you know he has his opinion on
things I have mine you know like I
didn't say kick the kids out of school I
said that you know there's got to be
some type of consequence and then when
the president has to get involved what
alibaba's president has to get involved
with on foreign soil in a communist
country you know I think that's pretty
extreme and I look I don't know the kids
I'm not having making a commentary on
good kids bad kids I you know I know
some of their high school coaches and
their coaches and I doubt so they all
vouch for them but this has become an
international incident and if they were
not basketball players and the similar
thing happened they'd still be in China
but synthesis about the act or the
coverage of the act here no III don't
know what the laws are in China and I
don't know the the dollar figure like it
you know it I don't I don't know what
they stole or allegedly stole because I
mean no no no really knows what exactly
they stole it was one report it was
three different stores but if it's over
a certain amount of money it becomes a
felony and if it's a felony I note the
schools I worked with or if you were
involved in a felony you immediately
take out of school I'm not on
anyone who kicked out of school though I
think that what about the stigma of
those kids walking around campus right
now if they go to class tomorrow what do
you think the stigma of those kids would
be they did something stupid they
embarrassed the school but you know
people move on quickly now it's it's
like hey we're outraged there's an
uproar and then you move on and in a
month from now I don't know if anybody's
talking about this it's it's not that
they shouldn't be punished here but I
think because of what they did what they
did it it it's now let's punish them you
know in a more harsh way than we would
have that this happened you know and
Rodale Drive yeah I mean what they
didn't where they did especially because
I've taken keeps overseas and you you
cover with your team or going into a
foreign country you know obviously
taking try to go into a communist
country there's a different culture
there's a different lifestyle you know
you're representing yourself you're
representing your family representing
our university representing our country
when you make a trip like this you're
ambassadors so those things that you
know those things I would I would be
shocked as the and his staff didn't
really drill that home you know when you
go out go out the groups you know be
good with people you know you know take
pictures and we want to take pictures
because you know it's going to be
different for some of these people I
don't think you can tribute eyes it
though then I really don't and like I
said I'm not saying kick him out of
school
oh you only shout a little accent right
there no I'm not saying that kick him
out of school and I'm not saying they
can't practice but I think there's got
to be there's got to be some you
wouldn't if you can don't it and you're
not condoning it three three day game
seems Tribble eyes to realizing it
that's me
I mean what how many games would you say
I probably do five I probably and you
know these games that start this season
are usually meaningless games
so you could you could have a couple of
throw away games in there and you know
set the tone you as you know coach you
take away playing time you know things
start to settle in and it you know
instead of I'm gonna scold you or
something like that but take a
way playing times a big deal so probably
five games think about the university I
mean like you're don't want UCLA yeah I
mean you're talking about one of the
really highest schools institution of
higher learning that represents a whole
region in a certain way if that happened
overseas to a regular student UCLA one
it wouldn't even publicize the same way
it would have been publicized but would
that with those students even be back in
the states right now no they wouldn't be
but they wouldn't be punished in a way
this is a big deal because you have one
of the ball brothers involved in it you
know you do have UCLA but if it comes it
becomes bigger because they're shooting
a reality TV show yeah and like I like I
don't think this is any reflection on
the way those kids those kids have been
raised I'm sure they're great parents
and like I don't like the way more
involve talks at people and you know
talks about other people's kids and you
know whether it's UCLA explain the
fourth quarter or you know when they
lost the game last year and answered a
boy tournament you know having comments
about the makeup of the team or you know
the ridiculousness of the Michael Jordan
conversations but that goes with it if
that's that's the scenario you're gonna
paint that's the world you're gonna live
and then you know what you're gonna have
to pay the consequence I used to always
tell guys you'd do something stupid if
you do something really good it's great
to read on the front page of newspaper
if you do something stupid it's not so
much fun he's Seth Greenberg Continental
Tire Coaches Corner in Spain college
basketball analyst joining us Dan
Patrick show so what you're saying is if
you're Steve Alford you would have no
problem suspending these guys if you
were coaching UCLA would you push for
them to be suspended the entire season
first well I don't think it's I think
it's out to see if offers hands I think
this is registrated decision there are
certain things that are above you your
your pay grade as a head coach and this
becomes the international incident it
became and the attention that it's
received this is well
of Steve offers this is Dan Barrera this
is uh you know the public relations
department at UCLA this is your asleep
police but if it's handed down that you
would because as they ever handed out to
me yeah and I don't know I would take
into consideration you know my
relationship with the kids in terms of
you know do I know these kids or I know
their makeup how have they been with us
the time they've been with us but I
would have a hard time claiming this
year I'd have a hard time playing in
this year and play some people say ten
twelve games you know wait to the league
play but yeah I don't miss trivializes
to go he's conversational mean anything
but you know let's leave starts that you
know everything's fine and we'll go back
to zero
herm Edward said something on Mike Mike
today he said something that you know
what you do is you see how they are you
know on campus you know they are in the
community obviously has community
service involved with it and then you
see how they respond good again that's
that that's a take I just think that to
me it is who that you know who who was
involved and you know you make a good
point you know if blondes or ball was
involved is she or they met at the
airport by that medicine at Lazo ball
but the ball the balls are they you know
Lee Angelo ball robber they met at the
airport with that many people
no they're not but I mean this is this
is a news story no matter who's involved
yeah it's a big deal with their culture
especially in the culture of what's
going on in our game right now all right
let me ask you about a couple of
questions we saw Grayson Ellen go off
against Michigan State and now being a
senior I don't know if you see something
different with Grayson Allen you know or
we should be looking for something
different with Grayson Allen well
firstly stealthier last year he wasn't
healthy number two I thought the poise
and the patience and his and his
leadership was terrific to me you know
that team when you're playing with four
freshmen
his role has changed he's now queen come
to and the rest of those kids are who he
was when he was a freshman so yeah I see
changing and I thought he he competed
hard
I thought that he played with great
poise you guys thought he played with a
really really good purpose and he's a
big-time player I mean he came off those
screens jumped up and shot it at a high
level and playing with a point guard
playing with Trayvon Duvel makes the
game a little bit easier last year he
had a place in point now he had it
managed the game they also had to find a
way to involve himself in the game
he wasn't healthy last year so he put on
top of that then he had his
controversies you put that on top of it
so I think here you're going to see a
different Grayson Allen I think that
he's enjoying basketball again and I
said that last year we actually had that
conversation it didn't look like he was
having fun and he admitted to it that he
wasn't having fun and that he got away
from basketball this summer and kind of
rebooted himself and got excited about
being in the gym being part of a new
team having a different role and he was
he was phenomenal yesterday in 2040
minutes is over how about that yeah I
didn't think I'd ever see that you'd be
borrowing play good zone oh yeah yeah I
think he borrowed a page out of coach
boeheim playing it plain to zoom hey
it's a great talk to a basketball
experience appreciate the opinions and
safe travels home Thank You Seth thanks
Bob appreciate it
Seth Greenberg yes Ben college hoops
analyst that's our Continental Tire
Coaches Corner for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]